friends
of storage
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys make yourself heard here we go
wow
you know it's wild man crazy
considering that we do this show in a
glass box with almost no feedback every
day this is going to be quite the
opposite ourselves yeah way better it is
way way better if you want to join us
the phone number is
888-825-5225 we're also going to do
something a little different today we're
going to take questions from the live
studio audience here we've got
microphones and have some of the folks
have put in a pre-submitted questions
that they want to work into the show
today so either one of those will be
just fine and we're going to start off
with that so who's up first Kevin
Hey Kevin how are you better than I
deserve where do you live Indianapolis
cool welcome to Nashville thanks for
coming in for this special event how can
we help you yeah so my wife and I are on
baby step seven kids are through school
houses paid no debts
um about two years ago we maxed out our
401k and Roth and everything else as
full as we could then the market of
course went South and we decided to back
off to 15 on our 401ks we focused on
cash and putting a little money into our
house remodel
and the question is when do we get back
in what's a good sign
okay the wrong question
um the the right question is should I
have done that no you should not
um because there is all kinds of data
points all kinds of pieces of research
and you can go back through and study
the history of the stock market of
people who try to do what you're doing
which is called timing the market I'm
going to get out when it's high and in
when it's low would be the theory but
most people do quite the opposite of
that because they're emotionally driven
and they get out when it's low
and back in when it's high oh it's great
I'm getting in well it's exactly the
wrong time so the people if you compare
mathematically people that jump in and
out and try to catch those waves with
people who just get in and stay in
they are the ones that get in and stay
in outperform them about 40 percent it's
crazy how much the math changes so
that's why we always say no one gets
hurt on a roller coaster except those
that jump off in the middle so what I
would tell you is any time that you're
not in the market is a good time to get
in and then stay in and and so the other
thing is the market is down right now
and all but one time in the last 100
years when the market has been down the
year following is excellent and so if
you were going to violate all that stuff
I just said a minute ago and try to time
the market now's an excellent time to be
investing because it's on sale right now
you're at you're we used to when I was a
kid we'd go to Kmart anybody remember
Kmart come on and um they put these blue
lights up
special you know and uh and it's on sale
and that's what the market is when it
goes down it's on sale and you want to
get in for sure yeah and the thing about
that is you know the Market's always
fluctuating but as long long as you stay
on you're on the ride the moment you get
out and sell you're locking in that loss
and so you've just taken that you've
officially taken the hit once you get
out and so that's why I mean just stay
in it because it's going to adjust it's
normal and I think that's the thing that
folks need to get in their head these
adjustments it's normal it's cyclical
this is what we should expect we
shouldn't expect for it to just be
skyrocketing all the time it's
constantly changing and adjusting but we
know by looking at you know the history
and track record that although it's
going and fluctuating it's always
tracking upward even though it's
adjusting so that's really that gives me
peace at night and uh you know we're all
in here with you and we're keeping our
money in the market man amen thank you
Kevin good question John I had a yeah
I read a piece of research and I'm
curious your take on this as as a PhD in
counseling that there's something about
the human brain that the the financial
people have found with surveys that it
takes three dollars of gain to
emotionally offset the damage that one
dollar of loss did yeah I I think it may
even be more than that now but it it
takes we're so lost averse that's just
the way our bodies are designed because
they're over so many thousands of years
there was so much scarcity so it's just
designed for
um hanging onto loss hanging onto loss
and man it takes a it takes some gain to
get back to that equilibrium and even
then your body puts a GPS pin in that
loss and it always wants you to remember
remember that time we lost remember that
time we lost remember tummy lost and
that works with money that works with
your marriage that works with your kids
that works with traum all that stuff
because your body's trying to remind you
well and what ends up happening is then
we uh the little drama queen that lives
inside of us overstates this crap my
drama queen is incredible
that's so loud
well I was going to actually ask Kevin
like here's what I know about me I get
hyper emotional about this stuff and so
literally once a quarter when the the
things are coming out my smart investor
Pro will call me and say you're going to
get some mail
probably don't open it you're good
you're good and I'll say well what does
that mean it says you're good right but
this is I I've actually had to Outsource
comments throw it on there like their
little Outlook a little Tickler call
John
yes well they know I'm gonna call them
with a hundred questions that I got off
of YouTube like oh yeah what if the
dollar goes away and we're trading rocks
and what and he's like dude I'm just
gonna call him
yeah that that is what happens but then
people say things like well you know in
08 I lost everything in the stock market
I didn't no you did and if you did it's
because exactly it's not possible
because you're still here unless you had
it in a single stock and that company
went broke but if you were in mutual
funds you did not lose everything it's
mathematically impossible it it actually
only went in half
that's true she only lost half and you
didn't even lose half unless you
happened to bail out at exactly the
bottom which is a a unique ability to
get out at exactly the bottom
that's one of my gifts Dave it's one of
my gifts
so the trick is it's it
I think over the years I'm watching this
stuff personal finance is 80 Behavior 20
head knowledge and over the years of
watching this stuff the way I have
learned to overcome the inner drama
queen is just an act of my intellectual
will I'm going to use my freaking brain
instead of the drama queen that says the
world's coming to an end
you know yeah I've got to look at the
actual data points and say
jumping in and out bad staying in good
for a hundred freaking years you know
and we've always had incompetent
presidents we've always had a Congress
that was handcuffed to itself we've
always none of these things are new
here's what is I think new
is this idea that the news is here to
help us the news has one job and that's
to get your attention that's right it
gets your attention when it says you're
gonna die and so you you click on it the
news is not here to give you info it's
here to make you wild right it's not
your friend not your friend this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
folks I know yes
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
cschm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
we're back on the Ramsey Show and my
excitement to launch this with this live
studio audience and here at the Ramsey
live event center for the first time
ever I forgot to say I have two co-hosts
sorry about that Dr John deloney uh
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling offer
down
a host of the extremely popular podcast
with Dr Chandler talking about mental
health and relationships and marriage
stuff and kids stuff and it's all mixed
in there it's a wonderful podcast always
very interesting Jade wash our newest
Ramsay personality
it is uh
for sure stealing the uh the popularity
contest around here without a doubt so
uh thanks get to hang out with both of
you guys today it's a good thing so
Ramsay show live from the stage of the
new Ramsey Event Center up next is
Catherine hi Catherine how are you
wait a minute there we go good hi
Catherine Hi how are you good where do
you live Cincinnati cool welcome to
Nashville how can we help today
so back in 2012 we came and did our
Consumer Debt free scream
and then getting to that point we
learned that we had the
um that our 80 20 loan was stupid and so
circumstances led us to lose our house
and then now we're 50 years old and in a
place where we could start thinking
about buying a house again but with
little save for retirement wondering if
we should just focus on retirement
no I I would get a house
um and uh the re I mean you don't have
to rush into it or panic but you know if
you want to retire with Comfort
um by the time you get to 70 65 and 70
you need a nistig and a paid for house
here's why
rents go up every year
period
the only way to control that is not be
renting
if you own a home the only costs that go
up are your insurance and taxes but your
payment even if you have still debt on
it does not go up assuming you do what
we say at a fixed rate 15-year mortgage
so your payment doesn't go up and and so
the largest line item in all of our
budgets or most people's budgets anyway
is their home their housing their
shelter and if that largest line item in
in your budget is going to go up
continually through retirement it'll
bust the bank
and so you don't want to start at age 65
renting through age 85 that's 20 years
of rent increases that's going to crack
and scramble in this day so we want to
get the house and then we want to get it
paid off as part of your 2025 year plan
from today so yeah I would move towards
that again not in a panic but but just
to go well no been there done that I
don't like houses uh I got had a bad
experience no you need to do it again
this time just learn from what you did
before good down payment 15-year fixed
yeah and we know that home
is a major
major baby steps millionaire
equation we know that I think it's
something like 67 percent of
millionaires have paid four homes and so
we know that's a big part of it and
usually when we're looking at that that
that Shakedown it's two-thirds of it is
in the Investments and the other third
is in that Home Mortgage so I agree with
Dave wholeheartedly that that's the move
how much of this is are you just
freaked out to get back into this thing
tell me about that a lot
tell me about it losing your house is
emotional deeply traumatic right leaves
me not wanting another one yeah well
yeah I had a bad car wreck I don't want
to get back in the car so on your body's
doing what it's supposed to be doing
it's trying to take care of you okay and
its job is not to
think about 30 years from now it's to
keep you safe right this second and it's
going to remind you last time we did
this last time we did this last time we
did this so it's good to have a couple
of people in your corner that will walk
alongside you we'll go look at houses
with you that may sit down with you and
a realtor somebody that's going to be
able to put their hand on your wrist or
put their hand on your arm and say we're
good we're good this is right down just
you know keep it conservative and you
know what to do watch your budget you
know that whole thing and don't get
caught up in some kind of desperation
but as a Long play home ownership as you
said is one of the big components of
people that build wealth and because it
stabilizes your largest line item in
your budget good good question all right
let's go on to the phones and go to
Minneapolis Minnesota Tim is calling Hey
Tim welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up
oh I'm just having a real real hard time
trying to get my
um Family fully on board with this whole
financial process
and they're just looking for some advice
on how to get what what my girlfriend
your girlfriend
is that what you said
yeah run Tim run yeah just kidding well
well you know not just kidding John
Tim you have a girlfriend and do you
have children with a girlfriend
yes how many
one how old
two years old two years old okay so when
you say trying to get my family involved
you meant trying to get my girlfriend
involved
yeah because you don't you don't yeah
two-year-olds don't get a vote we tell
them what to do
yeah she also has two previous children
but they don't get a vote
well true okay so you have a vote and uh
if your girlfriend's going to hang
around and you're gonna make babies then
I guess you're gonna have to talk about
marriage and doing this kind of stuff so
that we have a team that is moving
forward with a vision for our lives
yes yeah
how long has she been your girlfriend
about four years now okay when is she
going to be your wife
well and I can afford it honey you made
a baby
you can afford it this weekend dude make
it happen
that's 26 okay anyway all of that to say
that comes into the equation of she
doesn't want to commit to sacrificing
for the future because you haven't
committed to her
there's a whole lot of relationship
stuff going on here am I missing
something doctor no no
Tim I'm not going to get on board with
your plans if you're not going to get on
board with me
that's what she's saying Echoes makes
that makes sense what what is it about
the last four years that you're you're
hesitant
because I've talked to 19 year olds who
have no dollars zero dollars and they're
like we're getting married and I'm like
well slow down and you this is four
years and you're like well I just need
to get some more money why is that
what's this the ring I just wanted oh my
God come on man you have a kid you got a
kid
is that fair yeah besides that let me
help you with this I've been married 40
years the Rings don't last the little
dinky butt Ring We Got Married with is
in the safe and has been prop promptly
and properly replaced with a much larger
statement
[Laughter]
I think that's a good point Tim why
don't you just get get what you can
afford put a ring on it and then you can
always upgrade later on down the line I
think I think you're using that as an
excuse to move forward the Ring The Ring
ain't got nothing to do with it you've
got something else that's blocking you
yep and here's what it looks like Tim it
looks like you sitting down with this
with your girlfriend and saying
I want to build a life with you we get
to decide we get to no matter what has
happened in the past we get to decide
what this future is going to look like
will you build this with me and when you
have that conversation then you're
talking about dreaming and you get very
specific and then that is where you
bring in this conversation about here's
where I feel safe here's here's how I
want to handle money here so I feel safe
handling money will you join me in this
that's a totally different conversation
then you need to do Dave Ramsey plan
like look if I'm dating this guy and I
don't care if we have kids but he's not
asking me to marry him and he wants me
to do things with my money that's my
money yeah we're having a conversation
you know what I'm saying conversation
that's free conversation
[Laughter]
well that's exactly what's going on I
mean uh probably I mean exactly probably
but yeah but the uh uh that's not an
unusual thing that people face and Tim
I'll go ahead and give you one other
thing and tell you this there's again
back to research and data there's all
kinds of data that falls under the
bucket in the bucket of the marriage
Advantage uh married couples old married
couples they've been living together for
a long time married have higher tendency
to build wealth they have better
physical health they have uh better
relationships uh but I mean it the
shacked up thing does not have a good
result financially long term it doesn't
end up so check that out something to
think about my brother thank you for
calling in we'll always tell you the
truth because we love you this is the
Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
I saw
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show live
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality are my
co-hosts today we are live with a live
studio audience right here
I mean Ramsay Event Center
a lot of fun today as we launched this
open this building and start to use it
for what it was designed for which is to
serve you folks whether you're watching
from somewhere else we're serving you
that way or whether you're here in the
room we're serving you Dustin and Erica
are on the stage joining us to do a debt
free stream welcome guys thank you
where do you guys live Richmond Virginia
very cool welcome to Nashville all right
how much debt did you pay off we have
paid off 289
737.65 way to go
and how long did this take you 86 months
okay and your range of income during
that did you start this when you were
11. it feels like
wow uh 95 000 and we finished at three
hundred thousand wow
wow okay moving on up the story here
what are you guys what do you do for a
living now
um I'm a registered nurse and I run my
own business I do architectural Drafting
and design and I have to say this
building is absolutely beautiful thank
you wow Dave Druid himself on the back
of a napkin not really yeah no it's a
great it's a great architectural firm
that we've worked with for the whole
campus so uh Grisham and Smith have been
good to us thank you thank you very very
much well so this is quite a journey 86
months I mean you all your own income
has gone through the roof you've gone
crazy what kind of debt was the uh 290
000. uh the debt was four thousand
dollars was a family loan
about 16 000 was credit cards over
twenty seven thousand car loans
uh forty eight thousand in student loans
8 500 in medical debt
and eighty six thousand two hundred
forty dollars in restitution when I was
17 which I'm very ashamed to even have
to admit and then 100 000 for a Parent
PLUS Loan oh wow man you guys were
normal and then some yes man so how long
have y'all been married
um we got married in uh May 2015 2014.
yeah
it's been it's been a long time you can
mess that up he can't okay just be quiet
dude take a dive it's okay honey and uh
yeah so about the time you got married
you started on this whole thing you said
we're gonna do this Ramsey thing it was
a year later we bought a house you
bought a house and then you realize we
can't eat
well we found out we got pregnant as
soon as we bought the house and then we
realized we couldn't afford the kids so
oh you can't afford the kid can't afford
the house can't afford it can't afford
food we had to live near family so we
didn't have family to watch our kids so
daycare was an expense we had to
consider absolutely okay so that
basically the budget just caved in on
you and that was your wake-up call yeah
okay so tell us what happened then
so Dustin went looking so we decided
um when we first set out to see what
daycare cost
um what can we do and he found you and
then yeah it was a lot to get me on
board I was like heck no
um because this is working so well I
know
um so then we sat down and we figured
out if we can pay off my parents who
helped us with the down payment on the
house if we can pay off our credit cards
we'll be able to afford daycare so that
was the goal so we got that done I think
maybe a week before we had Declan so
that was the start and then it's been a
long journey since okay but that got you
moving yeah but so you didn't just go
there and then quit you kept going yeah
yeah
um after that we continued with
everything and we had finished paying
what I went to school so I started
working I was in retail I went to school
for music Just Like You Jade hence the
hundred thousand dollars of student loan
debt that got me nothing
um so then yeah
so I ended up working in management in
retail hated my my life he worked and
got a job and then um
started his own business and that was
able to afford me to quit retail and
start school so we went back to school
when Declan was a year and a half so
that was about three years of just one
income during this time and then once I
started working we were able to pick it
up and then covet hit so I could pick up
all those hours which helped us to get
to that end goal so covid was was
considerably scary if you were a nurse
but you could also make boatloads of
money yeah five 12 hour shifts is a lot
with two little ones yeah yeah yeah and
and it's scary the whole time too that's
yeah but they're writing you large
checks so yes they are almost battle
almost battle checks yes so you found
the show as a result of trying to figure
out child care right you go you're
Googling something and you find it did
you guys ever get connected to like
Financial Peace University or what was
that on-ramp we did we started that uh
early on and then we attended that
together before we had kids I think she
was was pregnant no we had Declan and we
had already paid off about 40 000 and
then we went and did Financial Peace it
was just we felt like it needed to
happen so we could put all the pieces
together I didn't need to hear anything
else
Dave got Dave spoke my language and he
got me right away but but you know the
problem with just catching stuff on
YouTube and there's nothing against that
but you don't get the whole system what
you said you don't see the holistic way
how this is all going to weave together
in the end you can just kind of go
you're just picking out the little
pieces and if you don't see how they all
fit together it's harder so Erica what
was it that turned you and got you going
because you said I'm like no okay
um we finished in 20
2021 and we paid off like 130. he went
to ITT Tech I'll let him finish that
down if anyone knows and John has spoken
about that as well so my student loans
was in limbo I paid on student loans
during Cove but then I stopped because I
was in a lawsuit it was not part of the
mass forgiveness because my school shut
down
um and so we were in limbo for a little
bit so we were just piling up money
waiting on to the decision in the
lawsuit and once it came out that it was
forgiven I paid on my restitution which
I owed 80 000 left this was from when I
was 17 running around with the wrong
kids
um and the reason why it was so much
because I was with two other people and
the one committed suicide so instead of
it being split three ways it was split
two so I had to pay for not only my
mistake but someone else's mistake so I
had a lot of resentment and feelings
towards that and I almost thought like I
wanted to die with it
but once we got to the point where she
was on board the payoff her Parent PLUS
Loan it was all yeah debt free to you
really means free yeah yeah hey to
people people who have debts that like
may not have been theirs or they didn't
realize what they were signing up for
whatever
just watching you say that there is
something about your body posture that
changes when you say
I shouldn't have I but I'm just gonna go
do it because it's the right thing to do
I'm gonna go knock it out and be done
with it and you walk six six inches
taller I feel like I'm 10 feet tall and
it happened right when your book came
out on your past change your future and
that's exactly what I did it just
dissolves shame sometimes action just
saying I'm I'm taking it it just
dissolves shame I was very ashamed of it
and I didn't want to I don't tell people
this this is the only time in my adult
life I'm really telling people out in
the open yeah but I feel like I just
can't let it be a secret because you
talk about secrets and stuff I feel like
I I conquered that it's incredible it's
awesome all right let's bring the kiddos
up I want to introduce them yeah bring
the kiddos on up
so you brought you brought your babies
with you what are their names and ages
so
so the Declan he's seven and then Ayla
she just turned three all right very
cool well you guys changed your family
tree we're proud of you well done Dustin
Erica Declan and Layla
Ayla Ayla yeah 200 or I'm sorry I'm
gonna do it again 290 000 paid off in 86
months making 95 to 300 and a lot of
transformation during that time
wonderful story count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream three two one
oh man
[Music]
this shoot the Ramsay shows
oh
[Music]
my God
how cool was that
[Music]
back live from the Ramsey Event Center
with a whole live studio audience it's a
lot of fun
Jade Washoe Ramsey personality and Dr
John deloney Ramsey personality are my
co-host today if you uh didn't know I've
got a note here somewhere I'm supposed
to make sure I hit this that we are
going to be live streaming the first two
lessons of in uh the smart conference in
the morning with Rachel Cruz and George
Campbell and if you haven't signed up it
is a free live stream you can't come
because it's sold out so you but you can
watch the live stream and wherever you
are in America and we're gonna make that
available completely free did I mention
it's free go to ramseysolutions.com live
and join us for smart conference in the
morning Saturday morning for smart
conference good stuff all right Jay is
up next hi Jay how are you great good
afternoon nice to meet you guys and
thank you for the opportunity to ask the
question
get right to it maybe step seven blessed
to be on measure been able to live and
save more than ever I ever even imagined
possible in the giving phase of that
could you guys help with some how you
prioritize where you give and what are
the right things so that you don't feel
pressure or shamed with everything going
on in the world yeah
um you know sometimes when I get uh too
busy because I feel this this pressure
to help as many people as we can and
then I get fatigued uh Sharon will get
I'll get home and she'll go uh
hey you're not Jesus the job's taken
and we've kind of taken that uh and
applied it to our giving
you know we can't fix the world Ramsey
Family Foundation doesn't have infinite
resources as a matter of fact I would
guess that of the people that come to us
for the different Ministries and so
forth that come to us we say no to 95 of
them
um and so and they're all just about
every one of them are valid they're
really they're legitimate needs I mean
there's a child at the end of this that
needs some help and I can't help them
I've only got we've only got so much
money and we put that money on this
thing and that means we can't put it on
this thing and
um and so you've got to get comfortable
with the idea you're not Jesus you're
not God
um you cannot do everything that needs
to be done every you can't there's no no
person on the planet has enough money to
to cover all the needs of the planet
it's just not there and it's not how it
works and so there's no end to that
until you until you divorce yourself
from this need to serve everything so I
I I I don't feel guilty when we don't
give to those I feel sad sometimes I
wish we could I wish we had more funding
that we could do that but but we don't
and so it's not a guilt it's more of a
just that's that's a really good one
let's try to get to that maybe next year
or you know let's let's just keep that
in the back of our mind see if there's a
certainly pray for them we can do that
you know but I can't be everywhere I
can't do everything and I can't give
enough to cover all the needs and if if
me taking care of everybody is
um what it takes to get rid of my guilt
I'm always going to have guilt so you
just got to reframe it in that sense
John any ideas I I the two things that
my wife and I do one is we sit down and
what are things that we want to see
different in the world and we keep those
things really close right I love the
right hand and left hand like I it's
just a personal thing between me and my
wife like we're really troubled by this
or we want to help this particular
family out and and
that's that's between us and Them the
second thing is it's it's turned into I
don't play video games I'm just not that
cool it's turned into that type of
enjoyment for me going to Waffle House I
take my son to Waffle House every
Tuesday morning that he's a middle
schooler and watching him the first time
we tipped a waitress a hundred dollars
on a 20 meal
and watching her start crying and lean
up against the coffee machine because
this is going to keep her lights on and
him going oh man right it's that's that
to me so
um I I give I know it's helping other
people but honestly at this point it's
I'm benefiting I think probably more I
love it so it's just become a a fun
thing to do
you want anything I think you guys
covered it I have a similar story as
John did and I just think that
learning to enjoy those moments and you
know my screen says how do we live and
give without feeling ashamed and I think
that you know the Earth is God's and
everything in it and if he's blessed you
with these gifts and and you have the
wherewithal to understand that you're
stewarding that and you're being
generous and you're doing all the things
and you're doing you're being led as you
see fit then you know you're doing right
man you're doing the right thing thank
you sir we appreciate you
up next is John hi John how are you I'm
good good where do you live Findlay
Illinois good welcome to Nashville
thanks how can we help I was wondering
how to convince friends and Etc that you
can live without credit or credit cards
besides just example
um
uh
uh well I haven't been able to
um all my friends use them yeah facts
I've got friends and family members the
vast majority of them don't do a
stinking thing I teach so um uh you know
and uh so being an example in front of
them I
um
early early in this process I I the
first thing I ever did with this
material this biblical ways of handling
money was I was teaching a Sunday school
class at my church and I was so zealous
and so passionate I wanted everyone to
do this stuff because it set you free
and you can become prosperous and you
can become generous and that the
benefits are just unbelievable and I was
I was just so passionate about it like I
had discovered the key and and uh and it
was really disturbing to me that not
everybody was and uh so I spent a lot of
energy trying to convince somebody that
didn't give a crap so um somewhere in
there I decided I'd no longer answer
questions unless they're asked yes
and people ask me three hours a day on
here questions I answer them but if my
friend drives up in front of the house
which happened not long ago in his new
car that was leased
um he didn't come over there for a
lecture he didn't come over there for me
to tell him he's stupid although he is
um but he didn't come over there for
that he came over there to show me his
new car now if you ask Dave what do you
think oh he'll tell you now there's a
problem then because you've done stepped
in it
yeah that's the truth I mean but if you
I mean and if that's my rule that's my
that's my life rule too I'm not gonna
answer questions where I almost force
you to ask I'll do that too but uh but
you have to ask meaning that there's
some tendon some indication that you
will actually do what the answer is but
people who are running around this
culture all over the place answering
questions that nobody asked uh they're a
pain in the butt and so
um I just I just quit doing it I just I
love people where they are and if they
need me they know what I am they know
who I am they they know you they know
you live debt free they know how you are
and so and they know if they need to if
they hit the wall and there's a problem
and they go man I can't I can go to John
because he can tell me how to do this
and now that I've really screwed up
enough that God got my attention you
know but uh but until then you know you
just all the sermons in the world won't
work let me try because you can't
fabricate that moment everybody hits
that moment in different ways when they
realize man I've got a change or you
know you've you've got that I've had it
moment or that that moment where it just
hits the fan and it's like I've got to
do something different and until that
person is at that moment willing to make
a change looking for something different
then you're just I mean you're you're
hitting a brick wall you're running into
it every time because they you can't
create that for someone they've got to
do that themselves and hit that moment
themselves both of these questions to me
are about identity like I'm some I I
have value because I can give a lot of
money away or I have value because I've
got a lot of knowledge away and I want
to tell everybody you got value whether
you got something to give away or not
you got value just because you are and
if your identity is I only have worth
because I need to give you this I need
to give you this and give you this
that's not a problem with the receiver
that's a problem with us and I'm looking
at me because I'm a pathological Giver
like I got I got to tell you how smart I
am and the world's like no you're we're
good we're good so there's something
about me having to look in the mirror
and be okay with me and that's hard be
okay with my relationship to God be okay
with my relationship with my wife and my
kids that's really really hard because
culture says yell give give and I I just
got to unplug from that being my
identity yeah John thank you good
question Jade warshaw Dr John deloney
this hour here on the Ramsey show live
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
like I said we're going to be
highlighting shows all throughout the
out this time together and so I have
with me show producer Alex Chatfield
who's here and it works on the Ken
Coleman show
Ken's going to be joining us on stage in
a little bit but first we wanted to give
you guys a highlight of what he does on
the Ken Coleman show
[Music]
Ramsay Event Center broadcasting from
the PODS moving and storage Studios it's
the Ramsey show where we help people
build wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships we're here in the Ramsey
live event center for the first time
ever with a few friends hang out hanging
out with some good people welcome guys
[Applause]
somewhere around 1500 folks here in the
live studio audience George Campbell
Ramsey personality host of the newly
minted George camel YouTube channel and
co-host of smart money happy hour is my
co-host
foreign
also co-hosting this hour Ken Coleman of
the Ken Coleman show helping people with
their work with their careers and the
number one best-selling book paycheck to
purpose
[Applause]
we'll be taking calls from all across
America at triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we're also going
to take some questions here from our
live studio audience and get to hang out
with you guys in person in this process
so let's start with the studio audience
up first is Tommy hi Tommy how are you
hey doing great how are you better than
I deserve sir where do you live uh
Georgia wow good welcome to Nashville
and uh your question for the day my
question is so my fiance and I are 24
years old recently engaged three weeks
ago and uh congratulations yeah thank
you pretty much
my question for y'all is if you could go
back and talk to your 24 year old self
what are the top three pieces of advice
that you would give yourself
wow should we narrow it down there's
three of us that's nine pieces of advice
I feel you putting the pressure I'll go
fast and leave all the time so I think
the first thing is I would tell myself
to learn how to fail faster and what I
mean by that is step into things try
things faster fail get into failure
quickly because the quicker I fail the
quicker I learn and then I would also
learn how to get over the failure faster
so that's what I mean by fail fast jump
into stuff now not be crazy risky but
just try things do things that you want
to do and learn through the failure and
then get over the failure second thing
would be hang out with older people more
you know I'm middle aged now and I don't
feel that way except for after a round
of golf but uh I I think that
the people that have reached the 60s and
70s and 80s have so much to teach us
even now at my age and
yeah and I
I wish I had sat with some older people
in my dad's church more and and asked
them about life and ask them about
marriage and parenting so that would say
that and then I'd say you said 24 so
Stacy and I are getting ready to
celebrate 25 years of marriage in May
and so we I got married at 23.
thank you very much and I would have
said uh apologize faster and better yeah
because you're wrong yeah she's not
you're wrong yeah so he's absolutely
right so that'd be my three things
for me I'm gonna I'm gonna start with
this one for the engaged couple the best
marriage advice I think is to outserve
each other and if you do that from 24 to
74 you will have an amazing 50-year
marriage uh on the money side and on the
life side you have time I meet so many
people who are 22 or 32 and they're
going that I ruined my life I made money
mistakes there's no time dude you have
so much time and the third one is don't
squander it and so be intentional and
realize that patience is is the game and
think long term have long-term Vision
long-term goals and you'll have a great
life and a great marriage wow you guys
are good
y'all y'all ought to do this for a
living that's pretty impressive I'm not
sure I've got anything as good as theirs
um you know I I think one of the things
that Sharon and I learned through going
broke and 40 years of marriage is just
to we spend an awful lot of time being
uh talking through things and reaching
agreement before we move forward
so we don't do giving substantial giving
we don't do purchases we don't uh we run
our calendar and our budget together and
so we she says time to do calendars and
we sit down and look at okay I'm going
to be traveling here I'm going to be in
Salt Lake City this month I'm going to
be in Anaheim I'm going to be doing this
and you know we've got this weekend
smart conference I've got May I've got
entree leadership so I know what my work
stuff is and uh and we've got this with
the kids and we've got this with the
grandkids my grandkids uh uh softball
and t-ball and soccer are on my calendar
don't make all of them but I make some
of them and they're at least there where
I can see them so managing our time
managing our money and being in
agreement on where they're going is how
we have managed our lives together and
it's caused us to be in agreement Jesus
says your treasure is where your heart
is and when you can agree on your
spending you've really agreed on your
fears your future your uh uh your dreams
you're agreeing on those things and when
you're not in agreement you spend so
much time in angst pulling at each other
and pulling away I'll do that
um the second thing I would tell you to
do is both of you make sure you get a
really tight friend group of people that
win
uh I've been very careful to put a group
of guys in my life group of men in my
life for 25 years now there was a group
for the first 14 years was a Bible study
every Wednesday morning at my office and
then after that it's been a different
group of guys or some overlap but for
the uh for the next 10 years and
currently today 10 of my closest friends
and uh six of those will carrying my
casket if I go before them these are my
men and they've got strong marriages
strong spiritual wealth they're smart at
business they're well read many of them
have written more bestsellers than I
have they're successful in their area
and you become who you hang around with
so be really careful who you hang around
with I mean you can love anybody and I'm
not saying snob people or something like
that but I'm talking about your crew the
people that you're spend time with
because you're going to use the same
language they use you're going to use
this you're going to read the same books
they read you're going to adopt the same
values they do you're even going to have
their accent it's ridiculous and so
choose it carefully choose it carefully
be not deceived evil company corrupts
good habits the Bible says and that is
very true so not nearly as good as those
guys but that's my two no that's good
and I would tell you Dave said something
that made me think of something and
Stacy and I have
we've just learned recently
walking through this but the people you
start out with
won't necessarily be the people you
finish with her it breaks your heart and
it's hard I gotta tell you and so be
okay with that so I would tell myself be
okay with that because we are we are
going this way this is the life that
we're going to choose to live and not
everybody's going to be on that same
Lane if we look at the life as a track
Lane and we're in Lane six there should
be some people that you'll start with
that won't finish with you and it's
going to hurt but you're going to have
to choose to live your life and you
don't you don't control them no you do
not it's not like you climbed the ladder
and kick people yeah you didn't say
leave us yeah that's not what's going on
that's right it's not you're kicking
people off the ladder they chose to jump
that's right or chose to not climb yep
or chose to
misbehave in some other way invalidating
their presence in your life they just do
that you can't keep them from it's just
uh it hurts hurts good question sir
congratulations very well done this is
the Ramsey shower
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Dave
Ramsey your host Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Ken Coleman show is
my co-host Today George camel Ramsay
personality is my other co-host this
hour rather we're taking calls from the
auditorium here our questions from the
auditorium floor as well as calls from
across America at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Chris is next up
hey Chris how are you great how are you
better than I deserve what's up
um so as you're aware The Total Money
Makeover was published in 2003
and I'm sure you're also aware that the
first baby step is to save a thousand
dollar starter emergency fund so my
question since the book has been
released for 20 years and with the
current dramatic rise in inflation do
you still feel a thousand dollars is the
correct amount to start to be successful
with your plan
a thousand dollars was not enough in two
thousand three
[Applause]
it was never designed to be enough it's
enough to buy an alternator for a car or
a tire maybe one or two uh it's enough
to uh take your kid to the pediatrician
if they're sick but it's not enough to
be a real emergency fund it's enough to
keep the little things from kicking your
butt off the get out of debt wagon
because what we when we first started
this stuff years ago I just I I said use
all your savings have zero
and that didn't work honestly that and
if you had come to Financial Peace
University when I was teaching it with
an overhead projector before we had the
baby steps I just was Hardcore just you
know I'm like you're in boot camp shut
up sell everything use all your money
don't whine get your butt out of debt
because if you don't get out of debt
none of this is going to work and but we
discovered pretty quickly that every
little thing that came along that wasn't
in their little budget the first few
months knock them out knock them out
knock them out and then they would give
up hope the people in the financial
piece would give up hope because they
couldn't do the system the system wasn't
working so we decided okay we're gonna
give you just a little bit of a beginner
starter emergency fund just to knock the
little stuff off if you have a car
transmission go out it's not enough if
you have something big happen it's not
enough it's not designed to be enough
it's just there and and to cover while
you'd go through the typically it's
about 18 months out of the 10 million
people have been through Financial Peace
University it's 18 months to get out of
debt not counting your house baby step
two now that means some of them do it in
three months and some of them do it in
30 but the average is 18. so it's
designed just to keep the little crap
away but if if your car blows up during
that 18 months it's not enough and it
never was designed to be enough so it
doesn't need to be a inflation adjusted
because it wasn't supposed to be enough
but good question thank you sir
[Applause]
I just want to say something very quick
about inflation because that's all we
hear about it makes you click and that's
what the media is supposed to do but
understand that the reason why inflation
is stubborn folks is now wage pressures
and that's fancy economic language that
I barely understand but it means that
hourly rates and salaries at our
all-time high and the reason why your
Burger King combo or your bread costs
more is because they're paying the
person in those positions at Burger King
and the grocery store more so when I
hear that question I think it's a good
question but let's also understand that
we the people still have tremendous
individual responsibility and power to
see in this economy where we have about
four and a half million more jobs
available than there are people who are
unemployed and right now in the gig
economy which means I go out and do
something part-time and freelance
economy there is more opportunity to
make really good money so if your
gazelle intense and at a thousand
dollars isn't enough you go make use of
more money and pay for that all
alternator you can go make plenty of
money in this economy right now that's a
great Point Ken
and on top of that the Ken makes a great
Point people don't think about okay
let's walk through that worst case
scenario you have an emergency that's
more than a thousand dollars what do you
do we tell you to pause the baby steps
and stack up cash really quickly and
most people do in the plan they didn't
have much more than a thousand to begin
with and so this hypothetical scenario
where they had so much money could cover
all these emergencies it just doesn't
exist if we made the emergency fund and
baby step one five thousand dollars we
would have a tiny portion of the
population be able to do that and have
the hope and motivation to continue but
Chris's question if you were going to
say the plan is let's say we got to baby
step three and instead of saying three
to six months of expenses we said ten
thousand dollars or fifteen thousand
dollars in 2003 now today would we need
to say okay that's not correct anymore
we would need to adjust it because it's
not enough if it if it was enough in
2003 to have a fifteen thousand dollar
baby step three it's not enough in 2023.
so his his concept is valid but it
doesn't apply to baby step one and the
good news is is that the other baby
steps are not fixed amounts that's the
only one that's a fixed amount the rest
of them are percentages
and so they flow out of that percentage
and the percentages will adjust with
inflation and with wage pressures and
with everything else so you know okay a
million dollars isn't what it used to be
in your retirement account true
but we million dollars is just a
milestone it wasn't the only target we
said put 15 away and maybe step four and
hopefully 10 million is what you get you
know I mean uh so you know it's adjusted
that way uh and so three to six months
of expenses your expenses have changed
since 2003. they should have yeah and so
your emergency fund would need to be
bigger today your baby step three one so
his concept is accurate in questioning a
number a fixed number from 2003 but it
also gives me the opportunity to explain
that baby step one wasn't ever designed
to be that in the first place because I
get the you know some of these idiots on
Tic Tac or whatever that are
um you know Dave Ramsey doesn't know
what he's talking about his stuff's
outdated yeah that's right it's how you
know the law of gravity is now outdated
so
but Dave you've you've told people on
air before you've have you tweaked tweak
thousand dollar number based on a very
specific situation
where you went all right fine you can do
1500 you could do 500.
you know what are the scenarios the
other thing I realized is that uh uh uh
this didn't you know none of these baby
steps came from the Bible they came from
our experiences
of coaching thousands of people and uh
so they're not absolute truth in that
sense uh they're they're based on
Concepts that are absolute truth but
they're not the baby steps themselves
are not magical all they are is a clear
path and everybody needs a clear path to
do whatever they're going to do Ken
teaches a clear path to get into a new
position in a step-by-step process
you've got to have a clear path you know
if you get ready to go to college and
you want to graduate there's a clear
path it's called a syllabus take the
freaking classes get the degree you know
there's a clear path you know what you
have to do to get there and so winning
always involves a clear path and a
process so that part and I'm aware
George that somebody's going to decide
to do whatever they want to do because
they're like grown-ups and stuff but uh
but I'm not going to vary on the air
because every time we vary on the air we
we not only vary for that single person
that's on this that we're talking to but
22 million other people are listening
and so then you start to blow up the
whole idea and the beauty of the baby
steps of the clear path including the
one that Ken uses is uh we don't vary
from it because it it and then people
start to believe it because it's a
proven path it's a proven system and if
you submit yourself to a proven system
then you can you can hit those goals so
it's a good it's a really good
discussion everyone thinks they're
special everyone thinks they're unique
they're the outlier you know like well
Dave you don't understand my situation
you are but that doesn't exclude you
from the law of gravity yeah yeah that's
right yeah I'm special you're going to
hit the sidewalk shut up I mean it's
like you know that's it I mean you're
not you're special but you're not you
know that we all are I mean you're
unique you have unique situations and
that's what makes the show interesting
people calling in with unique uh family
life and unique situations you're going
that's cray-cray you know it's
entertaining you know and but the
principles that we guide Our Lives by
um you know like you all told a young
guy there you know be sure you apologize
early and often that's a great principle
okay does it apply every single time no
I don't need to apologize to my wife if
she runs over me with a car you know
it's her fault you know that's a very
specific scenario I don't know but I'm
just trying to think of something
bizarre right you know somebody
misbehaving you know so but but but is
apologizing a good principle you bet it
is quickly early and often you bet it is
it's a wonderful it's a sign of strength
of confidence of humility it's a you
know it's weak people they can't
apologize it requires courage so it's a
you know those are those are simple
things but these simple Concepts do
apply universally this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
watch and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
thank you
[Music]
Fonzi jump in the shark
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show we're live in the Ramsey
Event Center with 1500 of our closest
friends
[Applause]
George Campbell Ramsey personality uh
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host we uh uh what you may not know
about the Ramsey personalities we
actually enjoy hanging out uh together
all the time anyway and so we get up
here and cut up uh it's kind of like
what it is when we're sitting in a
meeting somewhere we just cut up and
carry and argue and fuss and fight and
make fun of each other and everything
else so it's kind of part of the gig and
we just enjoy hanging out with each
other because
um I like hanging out with smart people
it's a good thing hey by the way uh
speaking of smart people thank you guys
so much for helping us promote this show
uh this week we are number 11 podcast in
the entire world
[Applause]
sometimes when someone says they're a
number something podcast or a number
something best-selling book they're like
okay I'm the number one best-selling
book on Amazon among people who own
French Bulldogs or whatever I mean these
little nuanced categories but this is
the entire freaking Universe of three
million plus podcasts we're number 11.
so thank you guys very very much
our guys are for some reason they are
desperate to be in the top ten you can
help us if you share the podcast uh if
you share a link on it if you let people
know that we're out here if you leave a
review a five-star review if you want to
leave one star mama said if you ain't
got nothing nice to say don't say
anything at all don't bother just keep
your butt moving on to something else if
you don't like it it's okay and it's
what we do and probably not going to
stop doing it this way so anyway move on
and thank you for that and uh so
I don't want to so share subscribe leave
a review that's it yeah do all those
things click the follow button and all
that stuff right yep on Spotify it's now
follow or not apple as well uh yeah okay
so follow follow thank George Georgia
knows the technology that's good so yeah
I just have people that tell me what to
do around here that know these things so
all right let's go uh move back to the
studio audience Jessica is here hi
Jessica how are you great how are you
better than I deserve where do you live
Fort Worth Texas ah love Fort Worth
welcome to Nashville how can we help my
husband and I are debt free except for
our mortgage yay thank you thanks to you
guys
so here's my question I've been waiting
to see what is going to happen to our
credit score now that we have no other
debt except our mortgage I'm not sure if
it's going to eventually become
unreportable or if it's just gonna
dwindle down and make it harder for us
to buy another house which we might be
doing in the next year or so so what
will happen to our credit score
well we're not sure to be honest with
you because uh uh the folks at FICO hold
for good reason and they should hold the
details of their algorithm very tightly
because if they didn't then people would
spend their entire lives trying to
manipulate their score so they should
not put out how this works but what we
think we see number one aside aside from
that we do know that if you have zero
activity and zero accounts open of any
kind the only thing are reported are
closed paid off accounts that in
somewhere around six months as you said
your score will be undeterminable but
you have an account that's open it's
called a mortgage so you're sitting
there paying the payment paying the
payment paying the payment wait a minute
I got a test case right here you had a
mortgage and then you paid it off before
you paid it and you had no score when
you got the mortgage correct so you I
would assume you got a score after that
so what you're sitting there with one
account a mortgage paying it what
happened to the score it disappears
after six or seven months no after you
paid the house off oh it's six round
while you were paying the house though
you had a school I created a score and
it was a good score go down low after it
came in no what was your score do you
know uh I think it was in the 700s so
with just a single house payment paying
it on time no other accounts at all you
had a 700 yes and you'll be fine
so it's not going to ding you now here's
the thing if you're going to buy a house
within six months after you pay it off
you think or would it be a while
we're probably about a year out from
buying a house and we've been debt free
except the mortgage for a little over a
year but you're not going to pay off the
house before you probably won't buy yeah
we probably won't pay it off okay so
you're going to be sitting there just
paying a payment like he did with a
single one account open that has
activity on it and you pay it on time
you're probably going to be in the 700
that I'm you I've got a one person case
study that I base that on okay very
scientific um but anecdotally that's
what I've seen conceptually that's what
we've heard is that it it doesn't it
doesn't just like keep going down into
the 600s the low 600s even down into
500s right just because you only have
one account if you only have one account
you pay it properly on time it should
level off now you're not going to get an
880 with that because an 8ad is people
borrowing paying borrowing paying
they're trying to drive the score and we
do know that there's five things FICO
publishes this there are five things
that cause your score all of them are
related to being in debt and how you
relate to debt and how you pay the debt
no none of them are related to your
income your Financial Health your net
worth we do know that FICO publishes
that so the FICO score is not a measure
for those of you that don't know of
Financial Health it's a measure of how
much you've been playing kissy face with
the bank that's all it is and so uh you
know to worship at the altar of the FICO
scores to worship at the altar of Bank
of America which is a really stupid but
idea but in your case you've got a very
valid thing that you're trying to
manage your life in such a way while
being responsible that doesn't keep you
from getting this next house but it
sounds like you're probably going to be
I mean generally speaking that you you
probably if you had up close to 800 you
paid off a bunch of stuff and it's come
down into the 700s or you know and it's
and it should have leveled off and it
should just sit there that's what we've
been seeing in general and I'm glad I
could confirm that with you I just
realized I had one sitting here yeah and
there's three things that would happen
number one you guys upgrade with cash
which would be a cool goal for your next
house number two you get a mortgage and
you still have a credit score and the
mortgage company uses that and it'll
probably be a good score or number three
the credit score goes away and you go
through the manual underwriting process
and so either way you're going to be
good to go there you're doing it the
right way but the credit score will not
go away as long as you have that
mortgage on the books yeah good question
thank you for stopping by I appreciate
you being here today
let's go to Nick in Milwaukee on the
phones hi Nick welcome to the Ramsey
Show good afternoon sir afternoon
okay my question is I was told that we
should get a home excuse me home equity
line of credit to add to our retirement
profile
who who told you that what is your
thought I was told by our Banker that
makes sense that makes sense your Banker
told you you should be in debt
I'm so shuffled
wow well we're not bankers and so we
have your best interests at heart they
just want your interest and so here's
what I would tell you
uh the HELOC puts your home in Jeopardy
and puts you further into debt and so I
don't understand how this is a smart
part of like a wealth building plan the
smartest thing to do would be to pay
your house off not use a HELOC pay cash
for everything and not have your home at
risk because your home is collateral
with that HELOC
correct that's a safer retirement in my
book Nick let me let me um just be real
very very clear okay if you want to
build wealth the best thing you can do
with a banker is never talk to them
again okay
okay I have never met a millionaire that
says I used all my Bankers advice and so
I became a millionaire never once has
that ever happened it's never come up
they're they're they're
really really bad at everything except
getting you into debt they re you know
if you got a financial planner that
works at your bank don't use them get
another one because he need he couldn't
get a good job
I mean he got stuck at the bank I mean
it sucks so you know that's the thing
you want to do for sure that's just um
oh my goodness gracious yeah and the
second thing then Nick is to uh always
be sitting with someone with a heart of
a teacher and uh when you have a
conversation that sounds like the one he
had uh when you get home you need to
take a shower because you know you've
been in the presence of slime
and so it's you know but and we don't we
all know that feeling right and slimy
people and so you need someone with the
heart of a teacher not the heart of a
Salesman that guy had nothing to do with
Nick's best interests they sell that
that is what they do matter of fact I
don't even want my savings account where
that guy is he's either uh he's either
after you're with malice or he's just
dumber than a rock and both are really
dangerous this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
here with 1500 of our closest friends at
the Ramsey live event center
Ken Coleman George Campbell Ramsey
personalities are my co-hosts today a
lot of questions particularly this time
of year about taxes let's unpack one
from one of our listeners what happens
if you file your taxes late uh you'll be
penalized and if you pay them late
you'll be penalized with interest and
you definitely want to avoid that
especially if you owe taxes here's why
if you missed the tax filing deadline
you'll be charged a late filing penalty
uh a failure to file penalty a uh just
we don't like you penalty they come up
with all kinds of penalties up there
it's pretty cool and the longer you wait
the worse the penalty is and the more
the interest is the longer you wait to
pay there is no penalty if you miss the
deadline and don't owe taxes but if the
IRS owes you a refund of course you
won't get your money back until you file
here's an interesting thing too that
we've learned over the years people in
crisis with their taxes are in crisis
with their finances and their taxes uh
they do not put people in jail for
failure to pay
they will put people in jail 2579 last
year for failure to file
it is against the law to not file your
taxes but we do not have a debtor's
prison yet
um
and so not paying your taxes is uh
obviously not a good idea but uh you
know the big thing is make sure you file
and the best thing you can do even if
you can't pay is file on time yeah all
right because it gets rid of some of the
other penalties just on failure to file
so for God's sakes file your taxes and
I'm off the grid no you're not
you're just my favorite is the crypto
Bros who are like it's unregulated I'm
like what's the first question when you
fire taxes did you make money from
crypto
so much for your unregulated money guys
from America if you're if you're a U.S
citizen is taxable it's period I mean
it's just that's unless it falls under a
deduction under the regulations but you
don't get to go oh well I don't have to
report that it's cash no that's not how
it works so uh all right okay open
phones to this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we're
also taking live questions today from
our live studio audience from the floor
up next is going to be Matt hi Matt hey
how are you great man where do you live
doing good Green Bay Wisconsin very cool
good to have you sir how can we help uh
so just wondering if uh one of my
parents passed away if they have debt
where does that go
well when someone passes away what you
own
has to stand good for what you owe
and so if they have any assets like say
they had a house or say they had a car
or something like that those items have
to be sold to pay their debts before
there's an inheritance if there's money
in a bank account it had to be used to
pay their debts before there is an
inheritance if someone dies uh with a
negative net worth where they owe more
than they own then some of those debts
are simply not going to be paid they
don't you children do not inherit debt
in America okay our current legal system
you do not inherit debt but it does keep
you from you can't go I'm going to keep
Grandpa's truck but we're not going to
pay any of his bills no that's not how
it works okay Grandpa's truck is one of
his assets and so you can't just go I
get to keep the assets and not pay the
debts but uh but but you know you don't
have to worry about inheriting a bunch
of debt from someone who's got a
horrible financial situation all dead
and no money or whatever but you can't
keep things the biggest place that comes
into play that's really painful is if
one of the spouses they've kept their
money separate which is stupid and one
of the spouses has run up a bunch of
debt and they own a house together
and so Papa dies and Papa has 80 000 in
credit card debt because Grandma
couldn't tell him nothing right and so
but they own a house together well she's
got to pay that eighty thousand dollars
in credit card debt in order to keep the
house because half of that house is his
and it has to stand good for his stuff
and so you can't that's the problem with
being in Partnerships with people too as
you get into this exact same mess so
um but as far as you like for your
parents as an example I don't know if
you're talking about for real example
but if your parents died and had a bunch
of debt it does not wash over to you but
you can't have any of their assets until
that debt is paid and if you co-sign for
it you would be liable but as long as
you're not a co-signer or any of their
debt you're good the creditors may try
to come after you they don't have any
legal standing you send a death
certificate and it goes away people get
confused like I I I want grandpa's house
but do I have to pay his mortgage yeah
yeah because they'll foreclose on the
house you're not technically liable for
the mortgage but they have a lien
against that house and so they'll take
the freaking house if you don't pay it
the weird thing is you can actually take
over the mortgage and you're still not
technically financially responsible for
the mortgage but in someone's death but
uh but the house still stands good for
the mortgage and so you if you want to
keep the house you got to pay the
mortgage and so or pay it off or
whatever you're going to do so those
things stand that way but what when you
die your net worth is what you own minus
what you owe if there's anything left
only then is there an inheritance if
there's a negative figure left then
somebody's not going to get paid and
we've had to walk sadly in financial
coaching sessions through with people
where we go okay
dad died and he left sixty thousand
bucks worth of credit card debt and
they're calling me wanting the money and
I'm like well you don't owe the money so
all you got to do is get your dad's
death certificate send them a copy of it
and go hey Bank of America here's what
you get nothing which is kind of fun
but yeah because it's what you deserve
you want an 89 year old 600 642 000 on a
credit card you deserve to burn right
and so you get nothing and just show
them the death certificate because
that's what they get nothing because
there's nothing there dad's got nothing
he died in an apartment nothing his
clothes are all that's there that's it
penniless and and we've had to walk
people through get the death certificate
to get them off your back because you
don't know it you simply don't that does
not transfer generationally and so
open phones here thank you sir very good
call very good question appreciate you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
Ken and George talk a little bit about
uh this thing we're getting more and
more and more of it uh we had a weird
call I guess it was yesterday or day
before uh of a will that had gone bad
um an estate planning thing that had
gone about how important it is to get
your estate plan in place and inform
everyone the details of it while you're
alive well number one everyone in this
room you guys don't have to worry about
dying with debt because y'all are going
to be debt free with money to burn and
leave to your children's children that's
the goal
that is my goal for everyone listening
everyone in this room and on the will
side people think Dave they're gonna
like somehow die earlier if they have a
will but the truth is a will just is how
you say I love you to your family the
last thing I want is grieving on top of
a financial mess because they don't know
where to find half the crap the
government then has to decide what
happens through probate that's a
nightmare it's not it's so much easier
in today's world now you can just do it
online we've got Mama Bear legal forms
it took me 20 minutes and I was done
yeah well yeah I think I think I would
add is just looking at it as a father of
three
um and and by the way this plays into
life insurance as well and so I hope you
listen to our message about taking care
of your family and I sleep better at
night number one but number two is my
parents are getting older they're now in
their mid 70s and and talking with them
and making sure that they've got
everything set it takes the tension out
of a season of grieving and I think
that's what I've always appreciated
about what Dave teaches about that is
that it's very clear the directives
about what I want to happen with my
assets and everything are very very
clear it takes the argument out of the
situation and allows people to grieve
and then move on and it's part of
leaving a legacy we teach that all the
time absolutely you want to change your
family tree and leave a legacy have a
will so that we're not happy that you're
gone but we are not grieving over the
nightmare we have to take over with your
finances and the assets yeah I mean the
world's worst is a bunch of hillbillies
in the backyard where the metal detector
trying to find the coffee can I got that
call Dave he had a hundred grand in
coffee cans I said what's your address
I'll be right there yeah by the way it
still happens today uh since we're
making big announcements this is not as
momentous as what you're saying to
people earlier but uh I've decided to
change my will and uh at the time of my
untimely death you will get all of my
shoes oh that's such a blessing wait
what size are you
I I don't know if that does that matter
size kind of it killed the joke George
sorry I was hoping you were going to say
golf clubs honestly oh no you got some
nice clothes my shoes are worth way more
than my golf clubs
that's one of those like you know you
might be a redneck you know you might be
Metro if your shoes are worth more than
your golf clubs
I had to get him back he made the Gap
Kids joke I had to get him back before
the show was over there we go see you
walk into it that's right yeah mess with
the bear I love it kid Coleman George
camel this hour good show gentlemen this
is the Ramsay show George camel if you
like what you're heard episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
foreign
[Music]
actual amazing relationships
we're hanging out today doing the show
live with 1500 of our closest friends a
live studio audience possibly the
largest live studio audience we've ever
had on the show the phone number if you
want to participate from afar is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we'll be taking calls from across
America we'll also to be taking
questions from here in the auditorium
Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author co-host of the ever popular smart
money happy hour and my daughter is with
me this hour thank you thank you so fun
to be here we should do this all the
time we should there's a lot of energy
doing this so great y'all are awesome
the show is more fun when we're not in a
glass Booth by ourselves that's it and
uh Dr John deloney number one
best-selling author Ramsay personality
also my co-host this hour
[Applause]
again the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Evan is going
to start us off from the floor this hour
hi Evan how are you hi uh how are you
better than I deserve where do you live
uh from Kansas City cool welcome to
Nashville thank you how can how can we
help today
um it's a huge honor to be here today
um so I grew up in a Ramsey household
um I uh save I've been saving for
retirement since I was 18 and I have no
debt
um so I just finished my first year of
my uh career job
and I'm wanting to buy a house and I'm
not really sure how to do that when my
income is currently as low as it is
because you know I've just kind of
started
um so basically I'm just wanting to know
like what's the best way to save for a
house well I'm starting a career because
you know it's not like
um what do you do so I'm a production
artist uh so I uh modify artwork to be
printed on glass and apparel
um so what do you like uh 19 an hour
okay all right cool very good good for
you
yeah so I would say Evan if I were in
your shoes I would just be okay renting
I mean you're just starting out so I'm
assuming I mean how old are you I'm 25
25 that's great so yeah I mean at this
point when we look at large purchases
specifically even a home I mean math
plays a huge role in that right and so
so what can you do to create less stress
and more margin in your life well going
and buying a home right now that's out
of your budget and out of your reach
will cause less margin and probably a
lot of stress and so I think it's fine
to slow step your way as your income
starts to build to put more and more
away and it's okay to rent for a few
years I just feel like people renting is
such a
Negative feeling around I feel like our
culture right I mean I just feel like
people are like oh you're renting you're
just throwing money away oh my gosh
you're just terrible you're a sinner
you're like the worst
and and renting is okay for a bit and so
honestly I would be okay with it have
patience and have that have a goal that
you look out and say hey and four but in
four years I want to have this much
money saved I'm going to be making this
much in in a job and so have things that
you're reaching for but right at this
moment I would be okay just being
patient
good plan yeah you said it I'm just
getting started I make 19 an hour can't
afford a house right now
and that that's the reality that you're
in so what you do need to do since
homeownership and wealth building are
part of your uh one of your goals or
some of the things you're asking about
then you need to start seeing away with
your career how you are going to
increase your income and then that get
because that's when you're going to be
able to do some of those other things so
you don't want to have a projection say
okay when I'm 45 I'm making 19.50 an
hour that's not a plan okay so we got to
have how are we going to double this how
are we going to Triple this how are we
going to start our own business in this
area what what types what other ways can
I use this skill that pays a whole lot
more whatever it is and it's not not to
say be dissatisfied where you are today
but I'm saying for your future we've got
to say uh my friend Henry Cloud says
when you identify your desired future
yours is build some wealth and own a
house
okay what has to be true Henry says
that's not true now
and in your case we've described you
we've got to get your income up and that
may be the maturation of your career
track as you mature and walk through
your career that may be the natural way
your income comes up it may be that you
go I'm going to use these same skills
and go over here and make three times
more but for now you're fine and just
rent is patience today but
um you know the the culture we lit or
the the price ranges of homes and the
interest rate environment we're in 19 an
hour is not a house buyer usually as a
single income household and Evan the
other encouraging thing is too that for
you you said I've been saving for
retirement since I was teen and I was
like that's awesome so honestly when you
get a little bit more traction under
your feet career-wise and you see your
income come up you can pause investing
save up a down payment because you're
not you're going to be okay do you know
what I mean so even when that time comes
to throw even more money to save up for
a down payment pause you're investing
when that time comes hey Evan can I use
EU since you're standing here in front
of I don't know 1500 of your closest
friends can I use you as a as a as a
global issue in our culture is that cool
so right what's he gonna say thanks John
no thank you well I mean it depends on
what issue we're going to cover John
I I remember being terrible at math as a
kid and I loved it when we had to do
standardized testing and math because
they put the answer like in I knew it
had to be one of a B or C or D and I
always hated it when it said e like none
of the above because then it took away
like I couldn't just reverse engineer
the answers all the way we live in a
culture that says I want a house
I deserve a house I should get a house I
want a car I want a great marriage I
want kids that are respectful and that
love me
but then we look back at the variables
that are making up that equation it's
like I don't make this this much money
and I but I want to have be in this
community I want to live in New York and
I want to make 14 an hour but I want to
buy a nice house I want a great marriage
I just don't want to talk to my husband
and I want my wife to read my mind I
would have great kids I just don't want
to tell them no and just give them
screens all the time and haha and then
they're going to be respect like we have
to address the variables on the front
end of this thing and not the back end
we don't make enough money we got to
start talking to our kids we gotta get
more engaged with our spouses whatever
that looks like in the back end the
answer to this math problem will always
solve itself if we take care of the
variables up front we stop trying to
focus on the answer and get on the get
on the front end of that good question
sir thank you for joining us
teachers if you want to know how
important your job is just ask anyone
who their favorite teacher was I can
name about a bunch of them and they were
all my favorites uh have the biggest
impact on you without a doubt we have
the Ramsey teacher appreciation giveaway
this month sponsored by the Army
National Guard it's in celebration of
April being financial literacy month so
anyone that is a teacher if you're an
in-classroom teacher one teacher is
going to win a five thousand dollar
vacation to wherever they want to go and
two more teachers are going to win a
three thousand dollar vacation of their
choosing and so you're going to pick
pick out where it is we're going to
write them a check for that and it's
again sponsored by the fine folks at the
Army National Guard all of us like
saying thank you to teachers if you know
a teacher or you are a teacher go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher and enter no
purchase is necessary don't we all love
teachers
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're a teacher out there thank you
thank you thank you for what you do and
who you are we really really appreciate
you
Dr John deloney Rachel Cruz Ramsey
personalities my co-host this hour here
on the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well
[Music]
so Kate Middleton
oh way too much fun at the commercial
breaks this is the Ramsey show thank you
for joining us we're live from the
Ramsey Event Center with Dr John deloney
and Rachel Cruz Ramsay personalities
Welcome to our 1500 closest friends
thank you for hanging out with us today
guys
[Applause]
today's question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services here at Ramsey we believe in
making home ownership a blessing not a
burden so we recommend neighborly's
network of service professionals to
repair maintain improve your home find
the help you need at neighborly.com in
all seriousness people this is a great
company and they have a great group of
folks that they work with all across
America check them out
neighborly.com today's question of the
day is actually coming from here inside
the Opera inside the auditorium dini is
with us Houdini
I'm excited to be here well we're
honored to have you where do you live
Miami Florida oh fun that's where Miss
Jade is from that area down there Fort
Lauderdale area yeah cool our Fort Myers
area I'm sorry how can we help my
question is about budget I have a 13
year old daughter and a 14 year old
daughter and they hear me talk about
budget a lot a lot of times when I do
it's because I'm about to say no and
um you know they think budget this
budget that and I don't want it to be
negative I want it to be positive but I
think a lot about it being positive is
to give them the knowledge of what I'm
talking about kind of the intricacies
and so what age do I show them the
budget because when they see the budget
they see the income and do I want to
tell them how much money I make
how much money do you make
as they watch the show I'm like oh
um well combined we make 3 30 ish you
make a lot good I'm glad for you
you wanna jump out
okay so um
I would say our household growing up do
you need the secrets out so you can have
a seat I know sorry I was like
so we grew up never knowing specific
numbers
but our numbers are ridiculous
and and we're in the spotlight with as
celebrities in the community and we
didn't want some teenager running around
you know with that information that
wouldn't have been healthy
we're in an unusual situation in that
regard sure but I would also say if you
make even the amount of money you I mean
you that's a lot of money so I'm like so
so I can see the more cautions you know
what I'm saying like
um we have some friends and then they do
well and they have teenagers and they
they show them everything and they
actually have done this uh routine a few
months in a row because the mom was just
so frustrated with like how just kind of
like casual they were without money and
she took their whole paycheck cashed it
out and she had utilities here cable I
mean she went through their cell phone
insurance for their car I mean she
divided everything up on the kitchen
table like three months in a row because
she was like I wanted them to visually
see what was going on and I thought how
powerful that was so depending on how
comfortable you feel sharing numbers
there is a part of me that kind of likes
it and to kind of open up that and just
to say I need you to really understand
and see this and then on the flip side
when you said budget ends up being kind
of a negative when you guys get do get
to do great things I'm sure you do with
your income like you guys are probably
able to take some Great Vacations or
whatever it is say it's in the budget
yay we get to go shopping it's in the
budget you know like make it an exciting
thing so when you do say no no it's not
in the budget they still know that a
budget isn't doesn't mean no budget does
not equal no budget means it equals we
are in control which means also we can
spend on this side and enjoy but also we
have to have a boundary and a limit at
some point and say no so so introducing
both someone's something exciting
happens with them
and they go and buy something or you
guys take a great vacation just
celebrate the budget with that too we
did uh disclose when there were 12 13 14
15 the household operational budget it
did not disclose our entire income but
so that they could see okay this is what
the light bill costs this is what the
phone bill is this is what the uh you
know the whatever the taxes Insurance
whatever it is so they could see the
basic stuff because what we're trying to
do here is not control their current
behavior with this lesson we're trying
to show them how this is done properly
because our friend Andy Andrew says he
said we're not trying to raise great
kids we're trying to raise kids who
become great adults so we're trying to
give you adult skills and so when I'm
talking to a 14 or 15 year old I'm
speaking to the 30 year old version of
them I want them to say Okay the reason
I'm showing you this is so that when
you're 30 you're this you understand and
the reason I'm sure the reason we're
saying no is this and it's not we never
used the budget one time as a weapon
it's not the budget we can't do it
instead we were saying we've got these
goals this much money we're choosing to
do these other things with it and so it
means we're not doing this because
that's that that is how a budget works
is we're actually choosing that but what
we're teaching them there is a critical
thinking skill path that says okay
choices have to be made because you're
not in Congress you have a limit on your
money and so you have to make choices
and so in order to say yes you've got to
say no now so in extreme income
situations maybe you would use a uh an
operational budget like we did uh and
and if you've got smaller kids we don't
even get into that but I mean with
smaller kids it's about principles well
principles and there is something to say
about a dollar amount our eight-year-old
because they're they're doing chores and
earning a dollar or two here and there
and we went out to dinner after
um church on Saturday night because we
did Easter on Saturday night anyways and
it was seventy dollars to go out to
dinner and Winston said that to me in
the car he's like yeah I was 70 bucks
and we're like okay and my
eight-year-old goes it was seventy
dollars
because their heart felt like 700 how
many chores would that take me to save
70 so I thought I'm so glad that she
heard that because it is a lot I mean
like life is expensive and so when they
can grasp almost these dollar amounts
there is a tactical lesson where they
kind of start to see and uncover and
Rachel looked she just looked back and
said don't worry I'm re-wearing this
shirt so it's good
hey here's one thing I've done
differently with my daughter than my son
my son is 13 and my daughter's seven
um I over disclosed to my son and tried
to be super hip transparent dad with my
seven-year-old it's much more about
she's got the the toy that they the the
bank that they sell in the Ramsey store
the one she uses and she's got save and
give and spend and one thing I was real
bad about was in her spend money I tried
to also control that
and so I've
taking my hands a little bit off so she
wants to buy something dumb that I think
is dumb that's the money she's earned
and it's not going to be there if she
decides to spend it and I wanted to
learn this when she's seven not have me
curating what she's going to spend later
but she gets when I say this isn't in
the budget or we're not going to spend
this much money on this thing she
doesn't need to know the dollar amount
because she gets the principal right and
that's been super helpful and Danny this
doesn't come up in your situation but it
does come up uh if your family is in a
financial bad situation we don't talk to
seven year olds about foreclosures yeah
we don't know that that worker protects
badly from that and so what's the phrase
you have scare but what is this share
but don't scare and so you can share and
say you know Mom and Dad are having a
hard time right now or you know we're
having to move but you don't have to go
oh God you know because apparently you
didn't dump your drama on your kid it
becomes trauma yes to your point it's
really important to be honest with your
kids because your kids are going to feel
your attention they're going to feel you
weeping they're going to feel all that
and they're going to think it's their
fault they're going to be seven and
think I I'm doing this to Mom and Dad
let them know things are really really
tough right now and Mom and Dad are
scared
and this is what we're gonna do and they
get to see an adult be scared just like
all of us and then act like an adult on
the back end and not just scream kicking
so the moral of the story is in your
situation I I would open it up at least
operationally whether it's income or not
as long as you can put around it uh the
idea that we're not going to uh share
our family's income outside this home
okay we're although I've just made you
but yeah but the uh
but the uh uh but I mean I didn't want
our kids tromping through the
neighborhood saying my dad makes this
versus what's your dad made you know
that kind of crap right what do we do
you would
that was a really nice teenager you were
a really nice team but uh but somewhere
think about what that phrase means a
really nice teenager yeah there you go
so hey thank you thank you this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author Rachel
Cruz Ramsey personality number one
bestselling author multiple times and my
daughter is my co-host this hour as
we're broadcasting live from the brand
new Ramsey Event Center with 1500 of our
closest friends
[Applause]
if you don't know we do this show every
day Monday through Friday from one to
four it's usually two of us at a time
we've done a little differently this
week because of uh or this day because
we're celebrating the opening of this
event center but you can join us anytime
uh outside our Studios or on the glass
down in the Ramsey headquarters in the
lobby and there's always free cookies
and free coffee uh there and as you guys
have had when you came in today we had
cookies and coffee waiting on you when
you came in today and so you could enjoy
that same experience and we just we love
getting to meet the folks from All Over
America they stopped by on their way to
a vacation or their way to whatever
they're in Nashville for something else
and they come down here to Franklin just
south of Nashville and hang out with us
we appreciate all of you hanging out we
get to we love getting to see you and
talk to you and hear your stories and it
keeps us going it keeps us moving it
gives us the energy
and so everything we do at Ramsey is for
the people that are not at Ramsey
it's all for the people outside our
walls and you're it you're why we built
this building so as an example so thank
you thank you thank you all right Scott
is on the line our Scott is here on the
floor I'm sorry hey Scott how are you
doing fine thank you so much for having
us in here it's a beautiful beautiful
space thank you sir where do you live uh
Spokane Washington I love Spokane
awesome very cool how can we help today
well I've got a two-part question on uh
transition and patience uh my wife and I
are in baby step seven and we are
finding it a little uh challenging to
transition from uh intense to
intentional so just looking for a little
bit of sage advice from y'all uh you
know how we can downshift yeah
okay go ahead uh
I I think it's number one it's a normal
thing to face that because once you've
been Frugal you've been very dialed in
to let your foot off the gas and
actually enjoy the ride a little bit is
not a natural thing your body is wired
you've set yourself in motion you've got
this thing dialed in and now you're
saying oh we're gonna do something
different and so uh Dr John always says
on other things practice practice a new
Behavior practice a new feeling and uh
so some of the things that Sharon and I
did was we were very careful to make
sure that we budgeted money to spend
because we hadn't been spending anything
and so we said okay we're going to put
money in this category and we're going
to put money in this vacation fund and
then we're going to spend it on a
vacation and if there's a bunch of money
in that vacation fund we're going on
someplace nice
you know
and uh when you've been
you know head down on the grindstone
pushing to stop and do that is an
unnatural act
you have to force yourself to do it the
first time or two and then you get
better the second thing we did and I
still do this to it to make sure I'm not
overdoing it or under doing it is we
look at ratios and ratios meaning uh
when I was broke spending x on a car was
ridiculous
spending 10x
that on a car now is not ridiculous
because there's a percentage of my world
it doesn't matter so if you got a
million dollars and you spend ten
thousand dollars on a car it's nothing
but if you have five dollars and you
spend ten thousand dollars on a car it's
a lot
so that's a ratio and so uh and we often
look and go okay if we do this and it's
completely wrong or we forgot to put
insurance on it and we let it on fire
is it going to change our life no then
that's a small ratio it's a small
percentage of our net worth a small
percentage of our income then we can
enjoy that and it gives me permission to
enjoy it knowing that I'm not being
irresponsible
if you grew up like me I didn't grow up
with very much my wife didn't grow up
with very much money was a it was a
topic of of of war in our homes and then
we got older and we ran up six figures
so we did the whole thing right
Dave said practice this is I'm just
going to give you a straight vulnerable
cheesy answer from our very house
I travel a lot and I made the decision
for me I'm going to start parking right
up next to the airport and it's a
billion dollars and every time I did it
I remember not having that money in my
checking account for years and it was a
matter of ratios you can afford this
John it's okay and the first time me and
my wife were traveling I pulled in and
she said what are you doing and I said
this is where I park when I come to the
airport and she said this is ridiculous
once and then she was like oh this is
awesome right and so it but literally as
Dave said it's 35 a night to park there
something like that for me that my body
still feels like I'm 12 and 35 dollars
was our light bill and we don't have it
right so I have to say this this
sentence to myself
I wasn't okay then I'm okay now I wasn't
okay then I'm okay now and then I've
gotta I've gotta go do the thing and
it's something little like that but that
man that's that's that's that's been a
game changer for us you know what's
interesting Scott I feel like we talked
to a lot of people that are just like
you they have this question and they say
oh my God even when they get into baby
steps four five and six like we've just
been so intense and I do Wonder I'd be
curious what you guys think about this
too there is something to be said when
you go through the baby steps there is
those seasons of sacrifice
and when you're so used to you know when
before the baby steps you accumulated
accumulating for some people you know
going to debt for stuff and then it's
like oh my gosh we got to get out of
debt so now we're gonna sell stuff we're
gonna work extra We're not gonna buy
stuff and you start to live life with
quote unquote less stuff I do think that
there is a level of contentment that
starts to play into your soul where you
realize wow we really don't need all
that crap that we had yes and you get to
this point and you're like
some stuff I just don't care to have
like like yeah maybe I can afford a nice
car but I just don't really care to have
it like I'm good with my you know 12
year old truck and that's good too so
there's a contentment piece so I would
ask the question why do I not want to
spend is it completely out of fear
because that plays I think into y'all
but I also think that there's something
to be said of like
you know buy a bunch of crap we don't
need and that's okay too that's an okay
answer so I do want to give you
permission as long as your motivation is
we're kind of just content where we're
at we don't feel like we need more
that's okay too and the last thing I
would tell folks when you get to this
point too is
to
um out of that contentment and out of uh
the new season that you're in you're
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
is um
Sharon and I have experienced that it
has given us permission to enjoy the
money
if a were responsible with ratios it's a
small amount of our life it's not a big
thing it may be a big thing to somebody
else but as a percentage you know it's a
small amount and B uh We've increased
our generosity
there's something about increasing the
building your generosity muscle bigger
more and more giving and more and more
different kinds of giving random stuff
just buy everybody's gas at the gas
pumps that you're standing there for a
minute or you know finding some single
mom putting tires on her car whatever I
mean all kinds of random stuff plus
systematic large giving as well but you
just work that giving muscle then all of
a sudden there's something that I don't
know how that's connected in our brains
but it gives us permission to be okay
enjoying some stuff
too and and so it plays out that way and
that that's how I would get at it so
really good question sir I appreciate
you bringing that up thank you for being
here God bless you
there is a thing of
if you're I said this on Megan Kelly
show there that I said yeah Megan it's
like if you're going 100 miles an hour
down the interstate and then you slow
down to 55.
it feels weird she goes well I've never
had that feeling
I said what you ought to drive faster
man
it feels like you're walking right yeah
I mean it's it's it's a weird it's a
your everything slows down and changes
and that's that contentment thing too
you know one of the things I experienced
on that Rachel that was uh personally
was uh I I love cars I always have and I
was buying cars in my when I was a young
arrogant kid for other people to look at
and when I went broke I no longer care
what you think so now I buy cars because
I want them
if I buy a car now it's because it's a
car I want it I don't know and it's the
motivation I don't really care whether
you like it or not you know it doesn't
matter to me because some of them aren't
straight I want I want to drop that I
like that car you know that kind of
thing it changes but that changes the
whole equation then when you practice
through that yeah this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
foreign
Matthew 5 14 and 16 you are the light of
the world a city set on a hill cannot be
hidden nor does anyone light a lamp and
put it under a basket but on a lamp
stand and it gives light to all those
who are in the house let your light
shine before men in such a way that they
may see your good works and glorify your
father who is in heaven Desmond Tutu
said hope is being able to see that
there is light despite all of the
darkness this is the Ramsey Show Dr John
deloney and Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personalities are my co-host this hour
it's been a very special day as we have
for this particular three hours been
broadcasting for the very first time
with our very first live event in the
Ramsey Event Center which is uh it is
owned by a a Ramsey trust a family trust
that is entitled Matthew 5 a city set on
a hill and this is on a hill for those
of you here if you walk out front and
you at night you see this thing there's
plenty of Lights there's all kinds of
this chandelier you can see for six
miles away uh this is a city set on a
hill this is put up here for the purpose
of Hope and so you guys being here today
is the culmination of that 10-year
Vision that 10-year dream for that to
happen and we're honored to have had you
guys today thank you thank you so much
for being here
[Applause]
in our studio audience here Mark is with
us hey Mark how are you fantastic Dave
and congratulations on the Event Center
this is fantastic thank you so much
we're so honored to be here where do you
live sir Fate Texas
uh Dallas area yes sir all right cool
good good to have you sir John's a good
Texas guy as well so thank you how can
we help today so my question is
um in your 20s Dave you became a
millionaire and then you eventually lost
it and rebuilt rebuilt your wealth
take me and the audience back to the
time that you had a conversation with
Sharon and you decided
your path forward was to share your plan
with the millions of lives that you've
changed
and why you do what you do today
wow thank you wow that's neat well
Rachel and John are certainly involved
in that and they can chime in uh uh but
the history lesson is you're right it uh
26 years old and some change I had Banks
start calling notes on us we were doing
nothing down real estate before there
was Chip and Joanna to tell you how and
um we deeply in debt lost everything
over the next two and a half years so
when I was 28 in September of that year
uh I'm turn 28 September 3rd and shortly
thereafter we filed bankruptcy filed
chapter seven Rachel was a brand new
baby she was born in April we filed in
September and Denise was a toddler and
so with a toddler and a brand new baby
in a marriage Hanging On by a thread
we've often said we got the opportunity
to start over uh the thing that the
overlay on that was uh when we first
started making money in real estate
before all that happened
was when I met God when we started going
to church and I met the Lord and so I
was studying scripture because I didn't
know anything it was dumber than a rock
and
um so I was studying like crazy about
any part of life marriage kids money
anything just trying to learn how to
live and learn what the truth of the
word of God says as a baby Christian
brand new and I again I didn't know
beans some of y'all grew up you know
going to whatever going to Sunday school
when you were two or whatever I didn't
know any of that stuff so uh
and then uh so I'm starting all of that
and then I go broke in the middle of
that so you know we've got on the wall
down there if you visit the uh the uh
headquarters down there I met God on the
way up I got to know him on the way down
and and so walking through that process
and then learning God's ways of handling
money I didn't set out to do that uh for
other people I stood out to do that
because I was sick and tired of being
broke and uh and apparently the
information I had from uh uh my broke
Finance Professor that told me to go
deeply in debt was wrong so I needed
some new guidance and so I shifted and
then we started Living Sharon I started
Living on those uh biblical principles
and very very very gradually we started
to turn and we started to have some hope
again we started to recover from the
trauma and uh recover from the destroyed
self-esteem destroyed reputation
destroyed relationship and relationships
and and start to just start to put our
lives back together a little bit at a
time after this hurricane had hit us and
um that we that I signed up for and uh
and so then this weirdest thing happened
we started a pastor call one day and
said hey there's a couple in my office
in foreclosure can you show them how to
not how to not get foreclosed on yeah I
used to buy foreclosures and then I was
one I know exactly what to do so I went
over and met with them and pastors
usually don't know a lot about technical
stuff like that if they know something
about money they don't know anything
about technical legal stuff so I got in
there fixed their foreclosure got them
in a uh uh you know got them in a plan
with their mortgage company and saved
their house and of course the problem
with doing something like that is you do
it right you get to do it again and so
he started calling me pretty regular so
I ended up helping a whole bunch of
people and I started figuring out these
principles apply to other people not
just me but I didn't set out to do that
and we were still I was back doing real
estate deals to eat and I think the last
year I did Real Estate I made 120 000.
and we figured out if we quit doing real
estate completely I just got on the
radio and they weren't paying me they
would let me do it for free which is
about what I was worth and
um uh we were starting Financial Peace
University and I was doing some speaking
and I had the little blue financial
piece book and we figured out the first
year we could probably make sixty
thousand if I quit doing real estate and
only did Financial Peace and we made 61
000 the next year
and so we took a pay cut in half and uh
but we started realizing okay God's
going to take our story
and use it to help other people
God's going to take the knowledge that
we gain from all that pain and use it to
help other people and it it went into a
career and then into calling and then
into a mission and uh if I wasn't doing
if if I took a pay cut from 120 to 60 to
do it I sure wasn't doing it for money
and I'm still not doing it for money so
I don't know you guys have been on this
walk with us in the last uh obviously
you have your whole life and then you
know in this last little while comments
on that
yeah well from just his perspective you
know we always laugh because we're like
Dave is probably dad he's probably never
really going to retire from what we're
doing so we always kind of joke like
he's gonna be 92 and he's gonna be doing
the radio show and we're gonna be like
yeah great job Dave that was a great
show today he's gonna go home because
we're like he's gonna he's gonna think
that he's doing it forever amen there's
gonna be a small little closet over
there in the just Baker Street just
plays on Loop and he's gonna be like all
right I'm doing it so I'm saying four
people listening how dedicated he is
though like I mean really like he he
really that is that is so true so so
true so but I know for our positions you
know it's uh as Ramsay personality is
it's a different
kind of a different door we entered in
to this message all of us in different
places in our stories uh but yeah being
able to to walk in this message and walk
out truly how it's affected each
individual as individually and then
what's so cool too now is that you know
as delony's talking about mental health
stuff Ken's talking about career it's
these other parts and these other
messages being able to give hope and so
as we stand on stages or sit in front of
microphones that we're able to tell our
stories and how this message is really
helped us and for me it's I'm that
second generation I am you know for so
many people their work in the plan and
they have little kids at home and I'm
like yeah I was that little kid you know
I will be your kids in the next 20 30
years and so uh being able to be that
voice of Hope For People Too has been a
fun
um perspective that I've been able to
hopefully bring I've never said this
publicly I'm gonna I'll tell the story
now this is a personal like in like just
for me story but um it's important I
think in this I'm in our history
um I I had resolved to not be on the
internet I didn't want to exist on the
internet I just wanted to show up behind
closed doors and help people and go home
and I like being on stage and all that
but I I didn't want any of the stuff and
I was finishing my counseling program
and I remember telling
um a woman who was one of my professors
a brilliant woman named Aretha marbley
Dr marbley and I she says what are you
doing because I was the dean of student
at the law school I was getting a degree
and I said I'm out I want to go be a
counselor in a small community and just
disappeared she looked at me and put her
finger up close and she said you don't
get to do that
you've got to make this world better and
they'll listen to you you don't get to
hide go show people another way and I
just put that in my back pocket and then
one day this guy called and then
everything's been different thank you
guys so much for being here
that puts this hour in the books we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
jesusolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started